I've seen too many examples in the city,
especially in Berlin, where half
pump pump companies blow things up and then
the people leave and then everything does
n't move together I don't like that when
you think you've already seen everything
then it comes back in the digital one
World the next new thing around the corner
in the case of a unicorn essentially
based on sex toys from
Germany for the global market the
incredible story of Johannes
Plettenberg lets go
so you actually grew up like that
I immediately understand what you
can research  on some
winery or even refrigeration or something or
is wrong yes exactly so dynasty
I would remove the term right away
but yes my family makes wine my
father built a winery in Bad Kreuznach on the nose of
Rhineland-Palatinate
that is now managed by the fourth generation
my father
and my father, as one of seven
children, also grew up there, but
if you
have a family like that, big or small, if
you have many children, you ca
n't divide it into seven parts, so
it got one of the names that was mine
Uncle and my father grew up in the
vineyard and then made his own crying
story, which means we
now have two weestories that
are my search father that my father
made for you himself but you would I did
n't feel like being too
hard first of all me  I'm not so good
with wine, so my sense of taste is
n't as good as the other ones in the
family. The entrepreneurial spirit was always
cool. I think I noticed that too
Christmas
big pack package around when
the big ones used to be ordered by many companies
that is today the compliance
can no longer send so much wine and
that they a customer we
had to go through the thousands of packages
that I brought with me I had a
lot of fun then on  Entrepreneurship
in the product sparkling wine or wine myself,
that's why I didn't do
it, my father
retired in December last year,
he's only 70, which means we
would have worked five seven ten
years at the same time must not
necessarily have been big enough
but made a career and then
studied in different companies
as a
salaried employee is always
the first two stops of his
career absolutely I'm 80 years old
so generation internship she's young do
what's looking for makes
sure that you have proper names on the
Curriculum vitae have the courage
to say to the next generation, yes, it doesn’t matter,
I’ll do it here, I’ll just basically go
through this small
company straight away
the train
builder who had his train headquarters here in Berlin
in the meantime
smashed up and sold
an ml and after
eight years always honestly no
longer wanted to if or on MML for others how
many deals were there at 8 years
in the first four years of banking
you do  some party with me were
very few because you I actually
only pitched like the madman
Excel models is scrubbed and
Powerpoints built the years Bombardier
were really cool
these making wise were more exciting because
when such a large corporation like bombed
but not super
financially well positioned  is because
the project business is difficult few margins
so there weren't huge deals there weren't
many small deals there used to be
the one for 7 million then one
for 20 million locomotives factory in
India sell to family buy
services business in Australia
and so there they like that  were small,
the management said he
just does it alone that was super good
because I really learned there I'm
alone Australia alone to
India alone to Poland traveled with the
Hungarian government negotiated with the
Polish government there
you really learn  a lot even if the deal
tickets
in the banking world were super small and
interesting and there would have to be but
then at some point you could also
read up on it
a little bit bored I asked myself
where is the path going for
me after eight years in  the one in the
subject I decided for myself
that I would probably not be as successful in the
large corporation
or achieve
what I would like to achieve
because I cannot play this political game
well enough, nor do I feel like it,
but I am also not that good at it
also to admit it did
n't see me coming up with an operational line
to then make it successful, that
means I was somehow worried that
I'd be jumping from group to group all my life as a hey professional
and then I said I needed something
new and  then I
asked around in the city then I also waited that
the whole digital world had become much bigger
in the meantime it was like that because
like that 15 14 15
and then I got to know a friend
of mine who worked together with leer Kramer at
Groupon
our industries the coal  so to speak,
they were built up, they
grew properly, it wasn't profitable yet and
nobody needs to help here on the
financial side and of course I was able to do that
quite well with my 8 years of MMA
and got into it and had
two and a half fantastic years with
amorelie the team the two of them it was
great  it was cool then it was already fully
sold and after the sale to Pro7 that
was relatively shortly before we have I
'll be in there in February we need 15
and I always have April there we have
two months now I sort of arrived and
it's just like that  that jo and he's
gone again i was locked in a
glass box like that it only has a
media room full of glass that an
aquarium and then i was allowed to crunch 200 deal
and then we did it and
after that i was allowed to go out and start again
privately and then somehow for the company
new owners exactly
but at some point they are out and
then you somehow didn’t feel like it anymore
The advent calendar of the super
successful invention of amorelie
the sexadventskalender gigantic
successful gigantic
and the second womanizer was the invention
of Michael from Metten in Bavaria, a 65-
year-old inventor who spent his life
inventing everything possible, not
necessarily sex specifically but
Earthquake early warning systems and
botany facilities and with that 65
saw a program where he learned that 50% of
women in the world are not sexually satisfied
and he said me as an inventor
I have to solve this and then disappeared
there two years that's the story in
his laboratory and after  two years at
Womanizer because our
number one sales driver was at amoreli every day
except for the calendar phase where the
calendar drove more and
Mr. lenke came
to us in 2016 I think or 15 nope November 15 just said mainly to empty
Police Sebastian hey  you make this
really cool here your brand you built
that's fantastic i would like to
sell it to you i'm too old i
don't want to roll it out globally it's
invented and i'd like to hand over good hands
crazy story but um what a
humanizer if you say  he makes the
most sales then let's talk about 10
20 minutes I
think he made a good day
25% to 20% sales from
amorelie but that's
quite a long time ago 2 15 were what 50
million for  three more like that then
maybe ten then today he makes
a lot more in the world and what is
that exactly this Womanizer because the
inventor of the food came up with the two long
thought up that I mean I am now
it is the trap for women
so the Womanizer is just  for women
we have now as after a group
we will come to what we do today later
adapted the technology and released it
as a product developed for a man
but originally invented
for women for
non-contact stimulation of the clitoris
there is one I think you have
University of California
conducted and published this
is the orgasms in the garden there are
many there were also had the orgasms
that says 65% of straight women
climax regularly whereas 95%
of straight men
climax regularly and between 65 and 95  what are
the two outer limits do you have
homosexual couples who must I have a
women climax quickly and
there was research into why and then there
are arguments such as
dealing with one’s own
body and
oral sex and the like that explain why
homosexual women couples
get strength  as a heterosexual and
lenke took it wrong that was afterwards
but you can have the same idea as
lenker who said normal
sexual intercourse is just not
sufficient for some women out there
we have to build something else
and then he has this pressure when the
vibrator is built  by means of a
membrane that moves back and forth, an
air column applies a
change in pressure to the clitoris,
which means that many
women reach orgasm very quickly,
many women who have had great difficulty in
coming before or who have never come, we have
people who write us out of the world
and  say hello I'm XY from I don't
know Paraguay I'm 60 years old I
only know the orgasm from TV
and since I've had your product
I've watched ten thank you for the invention every day
[laughter]
that somehow it
went well for years at  ambuli and then it
went on
then we were three I was I was
also allowed to attend the meeting at that time for
three we were hooked and thought
super cool that's exactly the thing
we need we weren't
aware of it being profitable if we were to buy it
of course not  with our own money
but not now we will be
profitable immediately and we also knew
that
I can't tell you what we
paid but what the company
made three million at that time so I can
say that exactly
from companies that are rated differently
they are on it  is painted rated
and less on top
is not so yes for a company that
was not a company at the time the company was was
also not forgotten is good neither the
two sat in their dining room or in the
living room Michael with his wife
Brigitte and have this company alone
her room led to two
three million Abit very cool there was
no bread there was no warehouse there were no
employees there were only the two with
good
manufacturer contacts in China and with
good distribution contacts in Europe
that means we bought Fast Forward when
I bought it  with my
group of investors we're about to
buy we're not actually buying a company or
we're actually just buying a product
with a supply contract and a
customer contract but only back when I
mean bought that little bit but that
means amore lies couldn't buy it
because ProSieben and Sat.1 aren't
wanted as
exactly that sounds a bit
negative now I steak or don't
I understand I understood that at the time
ProSieben was just that was
that was shortly before shortly after
ProSieben went
public when the DAX
rose and that  then the first
transaction after DAX entry would have been
as a European or global media
powerhouse with I don't even know what
billions in sales to buy a 10 million
sex films and the first
message in the badger I could
understand should be people we
can't do we don't want to do
okay
Yes, well, I can understand, even
if it was financially wrong for ProSieben,
my luck, because I
went home and said to my
wife, who knew that the leftists were there,
yes, unfortunately, that won't work, and then
he tells me you'll buy them  myself
how am I supposed to buy it myself I do
n’t have any money then just look for
money okay then I’ll go and look for
money
so his wife is also somehow
obviously very enterprising and
courageous but from home even if
Karin or something
started to do  Then I
ran around and talked to a lot of
investors, whether private equity houses or
private individuals or something similar,
went to MS Kapern several times
after we canceled, then
started a process with the consultant,
then went through a process three times, with three
different partners, I'm now  sometimes
kicked out due to sometimes
not enough cash sometimes not enough Enterprise Relation
and with the fourth partner that's okay
from Munich we then
pulled
the finance and you
introduced yourself to the
consultant who had worked for
sales and  then they said
okay so what they bring here at the table
is not enough at more or less with
the there you had to have the partner
like you just had the of bags so it
wasn't always just money there were
different things it was at the first
our our cash components too
small we demanded too much
reinvestment and
shareholder loans from the lenkes
the second the second ones
left themselves because they
were too afraid of the industry in the end the
topic of sex was great because we also have
one in 2015 we will definitely come later  on
top of that would have experienced gigantic
liberalization boosts in our
industry in the last seven years
the third one is
out again just before that because he said and that
was also a correct assessment he
said watch out I manage the
money of my investors I have my
limited partners they  have certain
return expectations
that I have to match that's my
business model this thing
either dies or becomes a mega
success I'm not a VC at all I ca
n't afford any assets that
probably have too great a
probability of going under,
even if I believe that  it will be
really great if things go well
and that's why he's out and the fourth
was then ruled from Munich and they did it
yesterday to be
that not so many others
wanted it but I mean if you
press three four different companies with it  can that should always be
a few months until it is
clear, the process is a little bit through
and you somehow
finished everything, so to speak, and then to
get a rejection,
then unfortunately there wasn’t much demand
after 9 months, the whole thing okay okay
to understand  you can buy something between 10 and
20 minutes
about
okay
[music]
and then you
built a company out of this dining room business
exactly so I mean we no I was the
first but then of course people quickly came
along we I could call a few who
already did
were away from a Rudi and said hey we'll do it I'll
do the whole thing normally here now
different same industry different product
or clear focus on product don't you want to
come back and participate then
somehow five six amorelie
colleagues came along that I didn't get from my colleague
they already left  were brought back into the
industry, some of whom
are still here today, who helped out
and then we are in the first year,
it was just a matter of
putting together a team that
is powerful and with whom I can do it together
because you can't
working alone doesn't work you
see and late 17 so I
started operationally on the first of May 17
and late 17 or 20 and that's the
core team that started it all
and then it started was fast forward
now the last numbers you  you
can see you make 400 million sales
today we make a lot of million sales
900 people around the world
okay so
didn't take part
at the time that would definitely have been the big ticket
yes it was quite good how much
I heard area 29 220 we have the
router group so  that became Womanizer
because we bought Reverb when we were 18.
It's a very similar story,
also because an elderly couple from Canada
who invented the second biggest innovation after
Womanizer, the
reversink or Psy shape,
which we bought and then where they
say in our
early 20s  Asian finance ministers
sold them the age there was then
the majority stake on the and
then what percentage did you have in
the meantime
I had just under ten oh even
with VoTech at the beginning it was
normal private business no
that means with that
money  but then you had the
deal, but it was only 10%, so
in the end you somehow
made further acquisitions, also
with other investors, and then
somehow
sold your ten percent in large part,
I sold two-thirds of the others and I
kept them and I did  I made more money from
the whole thing than I
ever planned
and I'm awfully grateful and happy that
you worked out like that but
that's what many say I was but I
say it too and I stand by it that
's not the main driver then
I would today  no longer sitting here and that
has to go on so that means
you found this Canadian couple it
's a coincidence that you
can also buy them that they then
wait, so to speak, that then typically
Germany somehow calls uh, it's
a lot now  a lot again
so that's just a lot that
came together at this point that's
often the case in life it's like that
the success stories
always have a retrospective effect everything is so yes of course it was
a great story easy and so but you
have to  can find doors
and you have to go through them she
has to see them first
and then she had to take them
and have the courage to sit down it was
a similar situation to the
Canadians that had built up for ten years
as a classic
Kleins medium-sized company
still in the hands of the founders  Founder was
operational but hired a cool CEO
Frank and I knew Frank
from America because they also
supplied us and when I then and I
also had a
bad topic with Frank where we are currently
arguing and then I'll talk to
someone else you said
I'll have to give up the topic now because I wo
n't continue which company I
bought with a group of investors
and then he says oh no, we have to
talk immediately because we actually want
to get out or my founders want to get out,
well, and then we talked, no  and
then okay you convinced your investors
to give even more money so that
you could also buy them correct I
added more myself
and then we bought the mai 18
and then how big was the group
then after these two and if that
steam  if you put the two together,
we were around 40 million 45
million euros
and 80 people that was at the end of 18,
so to speak, after the murder and conservation
for the whole of 2018 and then there were
other campaigns or was there the one, so to
speak, the one  Submission of the
majority then there was the majority submission
to them the age early 20s three weeks before
COBIT, i.e. before the western curve of the
experience,
which was an interesting experience because we
as a curve hit the right way so so strongly
against everyone that the company took a bit of a
break no one has anymore  Money
spent all companies said
okay immediately
cash retention don't let anything out
that means we have in March April doesn't
actually make me any sales
anymore because back then we were different as wowtech's
core business today we were
mainly B2B business we
also had little than back then  Buying it was
100% distribution business and then
we started to change to
supplying b2b partners ourselves and
working with them
like always others and also opening our own
online channels
and co. but since we were still very b2b at the end of 19
were annoying
because they all didn't because they said yes we do
n't even know what's going to happen now
not from what lead to no
more sales today and then
something happened at home now somehow
no surprise was suddenly all
people sexually buy because they too
Sat at home and said
what am I going to do now I’ll
somehow buy a pallet bike and buy myself a
Netflix subscription and I’ll buy six
stories and on YouTube
people are there to
do something with your time at home
if I’m allowed to find out why I’m having sex
isn’t it  well
okay then you're going
through the roof and you said
[ __ ] now I actually
sold it too early afterwards no
I didn't think once honestly
not not for a second yes is right so
financially I could have earned a lot
more later  but that's
not what it's about it was not about building a proper
company that you can pass on that
will work at some point
if I or others here who have a lot of
influence here and contribute a lot aren't
there that are there and don't
collapse I have too many examples in  of
the city just seen in Berlin where it
half pump half pump big and then
the people are gone and then everything does
n't fall together I don't like how
big is this company so yes yes
but last summer 21 or
the penultimate we made another big word
the  then with my
turnover of 100 to 120 million, there was a
merger with lafani, which is a
British company that is the retail market leader
in our area and
still is
lafern is
a marketplace ne so where then somehow
only significantly larger and above all globally
positioned
read so that here now also
makes a result it's
not so blatant so at least the
last numbers there always talk about a
result of so I'm now  not quite
sure if I'll be before the match
but in the single-digit million range
that's wrong so you can't rely
on the federal notification of individual financial statements
somewhere that's of course
not enough for a global company we
make significantly more profit we're
solid insulins double-digit
percentage range what you our  margin
concerns and ok
result of 80 million than as of
10 or so yeah that's closer than 10
years
okay
yeah right [
laughter]
and you own part of it too so but
part yes part of it and so on main
investors are telemos capitals
london and  just CD age they are the
two plump equity houses that rautec
and lafanni owned majority before the merger
and they both stayed on board
and it was just a
pure deal and what did you
push for everything what did you so
obviously want yes yes we are just one
is of course
if you I believe very strongly in
some kind of special competence everyone should
bring along you can then if you
rise up in the companies through the strong
core competence you can expand at the top
some call the T-model or
umbrella models whatever and
my tribe is just ml that I have eight
years I can do okay,
I think, and we are in the market that has
never been controlled by it. There are
few sectors, most of the sectors that
we look into have been
consolidating for decades
and we now have strong investors
and we have the team  that can and that's
why we do it and there are a
few others who have started it now
actually one and a half others who
also started after us and
I think in the long term there will just
be the three players who of course will never
have the market for it  too
big too fragmented but they
bring in the good players in their houses
and we just did the merger
and 21 with 22 in the summer
added the market leader in France again the lafani had gained
the current Swiss before our killer
and stuff like that  we always look we were on the
lookout for good targets
know the market well are apotonistic
enough to jump on it when
something happens and are also strong enough
to continue doing our job organically
and therefore shouldn't
depend on the front but see is very
clear  Time our strategy we are the
other
sextoi or take care of the sex there is still
Waterland from Holland is in
Dutch company also with
business in Germany they have
bought four five six companies in the
last few years including
amorelli
exactly and then there is Polaris in
Scandinavia market leader  bought but have
n't made another one so far
so you see very clearly you see this
trend very clearly when investors start from corner back
then it was more difficult for me
six five years ago six years ago today
we already have really strong brands that
look at deals everything  Signs of
liberalization and acceptance of
our topic
understood this is a real
strategic global game there is
something going on at the beginning it was
all driven but that up until then you just
stumbled into the chance you grabbed the
chance you just grabbed the
ground and  when did you understand okay
this is a bit bigger
here I can play a role relatively quickly in a global market
consolidation in a market worth billions to be honest
with
the merger
the killer of revipe which I think we
would have ruled without and would not have done  again and
again that
was a good lesson for me, it's better to
bring in a strong partner and
hold a little less shares
and also endure a challenge
or hard question operationally, but how to
get him, he pushes you and who helps you and
I bring the ideas with me  I don't think without a
rule we wouldn't have made it so soon
after it was a year after buying
Womanizer
we clearly noticed that
the market can be
played globally due to its circumstances and where it comes from because it's small enough for it
and the players that are there
are  some
come from regions and also teams that
perhaps don't have the same
training or the same
wealth of experience we we have with
people who we have
employees from Siemens from nestlehe
from simply advising companies where you
learn good business
that we have a very clear competitive advantage
be with us and then we
started relatively quickly
and now you continue to look at the day yes
and there are somehow in the
manufacturer area who make the products
as well as in the platform or
shop area that then somehow
just end now we
keep that abutunistically we
are  not so
the orientation of the company and as far as we are concerned we
are of course clear a clear list of
things that the company must bring along how
strong is people what stays and
rolls because
if we buy an example tomorrow
we will always buy some company Israel
we have we  I don't have anyone here who
knows the market so I wouldn't
buy it if humanity didn't stay
and join in and say I believe in the
story of the lafony Group and today I
believe in it I'm up for
doing it and I sell part and I
Roll part and on we go,
sorry shares that you
sell yourself again with the so you sell
and then you buy with the money you get a
new share back so technically
just about a part of your joke
is just for money and a part of
your shares are there  off for new shares
in the group
and that's an important model for
mebecause
then those without a chip and retain some of the responsibility of
the people it's
never enough you have to take a close
look at yourself and say you think they're
really doing it  it has worked out quite well so far
and then the company has to be stable
and has to make a profit and we are
not a VC-focused business, we
need companies that bring profit
so that we
can add bank financing again,
we actually make our deals
regularly with
bank financing or
position financing  That means the bank
pays part of the purchase price for
us to bring new profit into the group
as security, so to speak, and
we will continue like this
and a few words because with such
a model they are also crucially
easy to understand now you have to
somehow  uhm yes investors in the
background maybe they have larger
sums
who is actually rigito so that
mentioned that we which are behind it that was
your first big financier is
a group
is a facilitator is a small
team from Munich
which has a large network of
private investors  and they make deals per
deal in the other structure that works,
that means today you buy
Womanizer and from your I have to the
numbers I now think of your
100 or 200 people with whom you
make your videos come just the 30
people participate in you  together and
everyone puts in an equity ticket next to it
and tomorrow you buy a microphone
manufacturer and then other 35
people from your network join in the deal
and some
do not overlap, so those who are looking, who are now preparing,
then send their teasers
to their investors and say  hey who is
there there is no fund but it is ok per
deal individually ok but
thanks to you and thanks to the first
time with you they already earn a lot of money together
yes it was a great deal for
everyone involved clearly on the
operational side  why is this
business growing so fast you just
said regulation, because Corona was
an issue first, that somehow
helped you and regulation when something
else is there,
regulation time, I said regulation,
I mean I have
liberalization, yes, so we see a
small trend, um  in
social development we have
seen that the young generations who are
courageous are right but simply
no that
society says that as
always driven by the young generation
pushed forward they say
of course sex is good why should I
hide from the good  why should
n't I be allowed to say I want to have a sex life
just because I didn't want to say that 50 years ago
and they know it just as well as we
have a trend towards rented homes so to
help focus so I want to
approach it better I want to do sports I  I want to
sleep enough I want to go out and
have a balanced life and that means being right in the middle I want to have a good sex life
and that drives me enormously just the
loss or the loss negative the
courage to speak openly about it
to exchange ideas to say hey I
have by the way so
we know  yes that customers who
recommend our products to each other
that wasn't the case 40 years ago and that's a
strong driver Corona has
shot us through just to get home
I know what to do so why
not have more sex let's
grow now if I'm so strong
because  we were shot through this Corona Boost in
the dimension the whole thing
works for everyone in the industry in which
we first have to find new ones and
now the
energy crisis is of course helping and co doesn't
necessarily help us to say it honestly
because they're just people
we already have less money so we're noticing the consumer
climate especially in Europe our
European markets have been hit harder
than the Asian or
American we that I'm going
back to that there are purse teachers so
I'm looking closely because I'm buying right now
so consumer okay but the
change in  of society and um
that's just
a decade plus, so to speak, on the release has
become so successful on the same trend
because he and Sebastian who saw it back
then had the courage
to jump in and it works for other
companies in the industry too
and it will too  go on like this but
actually sometimes empty now and and and
and Sebastian also
surprises ProSieben and thinks there's
no such thing as [ __ ] uh I should have
done that or should we have
stayed with Johannes somehow or at
least stayed connected with him somehow
there are always conversations like this you
spoke
to ProSieben more positively I no longer
spoke to the little people who
made the decision back then
I spoke to people who
were investment controllers and
I should have said to KODi that was really something
Leon Sebastian should have done  we see each other
twice a year so that's why we rarely see each other
regularly but like that and we erm I
think we're friends and I
'm super grateful for the time I
had there and for throwing this
into or
entrepreneur water and I think that
both of them don't think twice
about the fact that they've made each other
but just cool that's out of the box
the company is now significantly bigger
than mine that's now a unicorn so
at least you can read that in the personal
and if he says 80 somehow
Millions of orders of magnitude result then
it is not that
surprising now it was just growing
a bit out is also said so
far is the question what do you get from it
old pictures still on it but even if
ten or or 12 is almost a
real,  -
yes, you can do that, financially mathematically,
yes, yes,
always the big search and I
understand that of course
everything is a lot of
PR, but there are simply not that
many companies in Germany that
have grown so quickly in recent years
and you benefit from that  now one
can be said to have been founded, albeit in
other ways, clearly organic and
inorganic, so without the one you could
n't have had the organic
growth, but when you play the white
together in the concert then it
worked out well, but you're holding up now
too  with all this unicorn press
and and and so actually back so
we have now also asked that they
noticed me I would like to
do a podcast but you are on the
lists you may actually be missing
maybe because we are more PE or
less VC the city  So does the
city or the scene live? You have to. The
scene isn’t just
based in Berlin. It’s also broader. Of course, the scene
lives heavily on VC stories that are
pumped forward on bills or the like in terms of sales and many
will also be examples that were unicorns
and then we are no longer there and
we are medium-sized companies of
classic medium-sized companies on paper as far as
our PN is concerned as a team as a
spirit motivation we try
to keep a lot of startup dynamics as long
as possible and everyone who
works in a company of this size knows and knows the
way  gone a lot of listeners
definitely do it from a young age the
white one that's difficult to keep up
but
because we don't
need any financing maybe that's also a
reason for more or no we do
n't need any financing maybe I'll have to
drum outside more when I
regularly from one to the next me
Hechel we don't need that we
work with the money we earn
and at some point in our business or
our investors just because the
business model is buy a company developed for you
sell the
company will sell the company again to someone
else or to them  Going on the stock exchange but that does
n't prevent us from our
everyday business the future is to be
sold again so that your
investors,
you don't know that yourself, yes,
we wouldn't limit ourselves today,
we'll see when the right
time has come, it's
not here today  for various reasons and
if he is there then we will
look at which way is the best for us
whether we sell to strategists whether we
sell a private house whether we
go public whether we go parallel
first to start what that will
attract  there
are already
a few
consumer goods manufacturers, large
billion-dollar corporations in the world that
may not be
doing something directly in our area, but almost
in our area,
I won't name it, but go
to the MS Regal and see what's there
Everything about health products
can be from the electric toothbrush
to condoms and other areas
for the intimate area that
are not so far away from the distribution of
our product and if you imagine
one of these large defencities,
our company now has a division here
like our division on
purely now you can
gigantic marketing and
sales machine out there that
sells photographers today and that tomorrow will be
able to sell all our products in every
single shop in the world,
so to speak, sell DM or
other stationary dealers yes that is
also for example for
liberalization and  the opening of
growth the market when we were 25 15
we were the first to list with amorelie
and the m were the
first to dare that
again the first mover the duck also came
from parts of the clientele
Shitstorm back then but the amount of customers
who applauded that was much
bigger and you could see that the
right decision was made
today, seven years later, we
actually sell the Group in every country, we sell
at Walmart in the USA, we
buy from Carfuren France or
buy from Bozen England with
Germany and  in over 100 other
mainstream retail shops in the
world shows again where the market is
developing, namely in the middle of
society where it also belongs,
but that means online for you is only
a fraction of the turnover or
half
75 80 percent  So if it's not Amazon for us,
but via your own shops,
then that means our
destination platforms, our brand
shops.com and our Amazon channel,
and it's still not
easy to advertise for it, so I mean
sex products
can't be on Facebook now  or Instagram,
so it's somehow advertised on Meta
I think it's also difficult on google it's been like this
for years,
so liberalization didn't
make it quite possible
to find other ways or
just rely on word of mouth
who doesn't help everyone enough  In this case,
we also try to fuel it as we
can, but that's not enough, you're
absolutely right, the American
tech companies don't let us advertise on their
platform, so no instar, no
Facebook and co. that's a shame, I
also think it's wrong, especially if you
look  what else is allowed
by the portal, but I'll join
you in the discussion of the
hypocrisy of American corporations,
we'll leave them here now and, um,
my frustration and
lack of understanding can be heard very clearly,
we'll find other ways, we do
classic marketing  still very clear we
do tv campaigns short spots where you can
see where they work that may be
ok i be Australia in Switzerland
e.g. of course we do a lot about
google so very clearly
they and otherwise we do the
strong blocking team almost 20 people around the
world the  Perl do for us in the
individual countries and try to
generate reach there that can
be a charming tip, for example yesterday we did
n't put up the poster last week last
Friday I think in London
refrain that's our destination
brand in the UK with a toggle  So a
money ball and next to it was silence is
golden Harry as an allusion to Prince
Harry and his
endless babble out there
that goes quite well through the
social media channels that's okay too
nobody stops that kind of thing e.g. or a
few years ago we had it  a great,
similar thing, we hung up
a poster with a partner in America
that said scream your name,
but it was also really good, something like that went really well,
or we do
studies that we publish and in
which we can explain how sex toys can be used
in other ways
can help on other levels, for example we
did 20 studies that was the
menstruation campaign or study
we sent 500 women from 19 countries
a Womanizer and said please
put it wrong so we trust is
of course women who
have severe menstrual problems and in
the  Time to take painkillers and said
please stop taking them and take them
instead where you
can masturbate instead of taking painkillers that takes
three months and then
she gave the first month as a comparison
three months test then in 5 months
again as a comparison month and we were able to do
that  a clinically accompanied study,
we were able to determine that
the women who did this were
able to reduce their menstrual cramps, why is it then neatly
packed into the results of the study and
sent out, and with that we get a lot of
reach because many, many newspapers and
or publishers pick up on it because it is
a great topic  we are currently doing
a similar study with the
charité results will come in three
months on the subject of
revitalizing the libido libido after
breast cancer in women for
example so
and third third big block are
social media cooperation ne we are
of course looking for many influencers and social
media cooperation opportunities around there
our products to be able to
tell our story by means of the influencer
that we are
cooperating on products because we can
afford more than just a single
post so with Lilly we have everyone who
probably knows a lot of pop stars
what okay
Womanizer Liberty special line
released
positively named  wrote her biography
and we did a cooperation with Body strange in
Germany for
wo man so Eco and we just
released a Womanizer Marilyn Monroe Edition that we do
on a higher level and that everything else
is above all broad and generate a lot of reach
that's right  but there is a company
in the USA that owns the right registration
and if you
see it comes from the same
licenser’s office as the Womanizer
okay
so despite all the future
sales are still actually
driven by let’s say these
two
yes
stimulation technology products yes that
i.e. Womanizer and sea shape, i.e. the
bottle of earth technology from the Womanizer
and the sea-shirt technology are the
top-selling products or
product groups for us, but
of course they’re now down to
ten percent or so globally, oh well,
okay, what else is there
on ours  Destination platform in
Switzerland in France USA and Co.
we only have a whole range there
we have 5000 products there we are a
kind of retailer only retailer is
too simple for me because we
many many of our customers do not know
what they want because they  are not yet
familiar enough with the market, which means
they come to us on the platform on
the side and are
coached by us
shoe i know exactly i
go on artificial turf i need the
nub shoe and i like this adidas
so quickly go to buy platform
speed and trust for us it's
all about education what i like
what i don't like what um could i
like what can i  no longer trust
what could the next product be no
we also have a decent
repurchase rate not so that people
buy a product and then stop
buying
also
we own one from our own difficult because
we make a lot of our own we have
so the line is the  a strong line the
overview is another strong line
then the artwave is that the
men's line plays a major role then
our lafoni mon amiris is our
entry-focused brand plays a
major role there are brands and then there are
often similar brands in the market
Products then somehow
vibrator there are the dildos talking about the penis there is
space inside there is the
masturbator and then depending on the brand it will be
different different quality
different price point and so on
and so forth ok how many
trades always the
70% own turnover about ok that's it
because if you
make 70% of 4 million yourself, that makes
a big difference, so that's
always acting, that's not that
valuable, so there are other people there,
the marches are smaller
accordingly, okay, so that's fine and
you can  assuming
that something is doing it somehow,
Amazon has always accused them of
looking at what's going well and then they do
n't want to do it themselves, so I always knew that we would find a product
that would prove it,
but there are also many products that
we made first  or where we
have added an additional feature that nobody has done before, so
we are because the market here is like this
and you, we are
the largest in the world with 400 million sales, so now the
largest world always sounds so crazy, but 4
million sounds  not now is
so when the other industry looks at
what the biggest sales in the world are
doing we have no idea
compared to that ne what really
for us yes we will continue to grow with
so if this if this dip this
Post Corona and and  influenced by war or
energy inflation dip is over if
we continue to grow in double-digit percentages
10 15 percent per year I am
firmly convinced that this will go on forever
we are not a business that grows at 70 80%
per year no it
will take a few more years and then
we’ll take a look  give a few more jokes
that means in the billion turnover
group you definitely need
you say the police are therefore I know 5
years 15% is double so that we
can't do it for the
reasons mentioned now the year before last
we are 15  last year
we only grew one, you can see the
influence of the current
challenge in the world, but we
have to work five, six, seven years because +
800 a little bit
okay okay that means you're going to be doing that
now somehow for the next few years,
so go there  I can't go
out anymore and
that's not boring, no, it's
boring,
because this constant
building I'm a qualified
industrial engineer, maybe that's
engineering, tinkering around and building,
which I just really enjoy, that
together with this great
global team is also a great thing too
back we're brutally global for the fact
that we only make 400 million in sales
if you look at the Germans from the connection which
are significantly larger that's why completely
different areas 500 million
billion and plus a lot of them
aren't as global as we are and that
's
a lot of fun  we know we have
50 my mother was we have
70 times in Australia to be
able to build this global business from here
is incredibly cool fun
why is it that mom often has
such
innovations or developments from the
sex industry in the broadest sense from
Germany so again in
dating  and partner agency Parship
and so there are also the biggest
players in German companies so
you can also do that from Germany then
Youporn the biggest sex video platform
now you can say there were
somehow Beate
Uhse and Orion in Germany years ago and so also from
Germany  well somehow the
Germany seems I don't know somehow
how do you explain that I mean that's
not considered a particularly
romantic nation or anything like that okay the
Germans are totally crazy about sex
so or so why is it so
good that you're still mentioned  you always
publish as an absolute pioneer in
this whole area at the time having the
courage to build something up with the
resistance that is really totally impressive to this day why
is that so I
can't tell you we are definitely
not as prudish as I think
many countries think we are
just because we might seem a bit
reserved out there in the
world but then obviously behind closed doors
we are not because
the trend is clear that you are
right yes so or is it still
buying so so buy  now they are
somehow more common or have more
repeat coiffe than Italians or something like that
or French yes with the Italians
you took the prime example
of those who buy nothing or almost
nothing exactly in Europe Italy is the
worst market and now
everyone can think about why a  Country which is
prescribed a macho culture
you see a clear correlation
Benelux roof Scandinavia are the
strongest regions in Europe and the
southern countries France has also
grown strongly in recent years
and Spain has also started to
wake up Italy is still sitting in the
sleepy do
n't believe anything
culture, the less
women dare to buy, the most expensive thing to
buy, and that’s why it’s less,
men don’t buy toys,
we have a lot more
women today than men, but we
sell 50% to men because a lot
a lot of men buy their wives as
gifts and buy Italians
I'm very super flat rate exactly
okay
needs then she doesn't need me
anymore that's not
exactly to hear
okay um well you don't know why that
's the case so that means you or
generally in Germany  plays a role
that's pretty hard to say
for you yes me well
we haven't
seen any studies where it says that the
sex drive of the Germans
is particularly pronounced so it's different but we
see in the sales and we see in
the example you mentioned that  we
as a society are more
open than other
societies and against i
think a game have always seen the
largest
stock of sex toys per capita have the
seven eight of them but now
says okay [ __ ] i'm somehow
good keep
buying what is actually
our AV about them  Whole company is like
55 euros
okay but we have
of course we start with products from 10 euros and
lower that brands can be a simple penis ring
or
a lube and we go up to
the premium so one of our best
products has costs 189 I think
and we have  also a few products
over 200 so the excitement is great
and AV is around 55
[music]
today there's still
the brand there's still
the company that was bought by Waterland
in Dutch entrepreneur also
does a good job who then has as Beate
Uhse for  the next time
the brand went bankrupt, it was bought and today it is known
as the Beate uh.de
success story and then at some point it went
downhill for years and then
takeover and bankruptcy again and
today the brand still exists but
not much more
that is the exciting story that
they know  I didn't know most of them
beforehand either Orion and Bertose
both come from Beate Uhse they are three
sons and one made Orion the
other two made Orion and
Orient is still in the family today
and have done a great job and have been I do
n't know how much since 50  60 years
they probably withstand every storm
and are active on all channels on
orion.de have Orion specialist shops have
organizational network and are there so you
can say if you ignore the name
a lot of the DNA and
culture is still there  namely in but they are
not we
no are actually stores for you
to operate a topic for ourselves we
did a Mercedes transaction in France
in the summer it fits plisil bought they
come with five stores
and that is a good test model for us
is let's see that  let's get to that, let's learn
how it is with stores how much
they are all break even learned make
a little win that's okay the
question is how much does a store like this help
for
brandration wellness because I
have a shop window and a headline is
overloaded and stuff like that  away that's
an additional element of
this deal that we've found right now, that they're just there,
we can learn there and then we
can decide a few years later whether we
want to make it bigger,
which is actually in the end, so to speak,
or a way to prevent it from being
copied  Can I mean now these
devices that you are building there I'm
sure some Asians are going to
build them who look apart Anna
what was he doing very much Mr Lemke back then I was
thinking okay clever but
we're already getting that in terms of network
effects and it's not  some kind of
software where you say okay
Asian companies and there are,
I think, um satisfire or something like that,
the product is called that somehow
gives you competition, what does he do about it, so
if I mean can't
protect it worldwide, so that will happen
and then some  sell another platform
absolutely
you can there is never a single
strategy in my opinion that
intercepts everything is always a
combination of several elements
or it may be
branding it may
be customer service it may
be innovation to keep coming up with new
things  bring that makes it the
platform on which we
best inform our customers about products that
may be patents that we have quite a
strong patent portfolio in none of those
mentioned alone is sufficient but
in combination you get a
very good USP
/ defense element and
play that  We're quite good, but there are many,
many counterfeits, of course there are, of course,
every industry has one, so let's
take Oral B,
no, it
's been around for what I've been decades,
this electric toothbrush has been in
every shop and you ca
n't buy Oral-B everywhere  but damn,
people buy B everywhere because they
play the game really well. Brand
Innovation
Representation at the POS, whether digital or
offline, a little oral,
okay, that's what I have in mind
if you think with it, I think the
advantage with us is that we  need more than
one toothbrush
than humans so i can also have more than
one sexually fun can also
grow and want to trust me more
that they do other things that
maybe wouldn't have done in the beginning
but i use that too baby example
often when  I talk to people who
say
well I have a vibrator and
then I'll never need anything again
and then we have to take your long term look
how many companies are out there
can you also use hair dryer companies
or all other consumers has
plastic consumer goods
electronic products
all of which have been there for 100 years because brand
renewal innovation
never stops delivering added value and if
I need even more than a
toothbrush or a hair dryer, I
still have an advantage over
how close you are actually
a little bit off, I mean um  are
you going to look at these little things
technically and say okay,
so that's understood, or are you, say
yes, what can you say, so
you've already experienced the use of these
things when I
was sitting in the S-Bahn this morning  and drove to the office
and thought okay today I'll talk
to you that I'll see how long it
takes ask the question
[laughter]
we well I'll answer it like this
when we bought vivap
invented a new masturbator developed produced
and that was it  developed by three
guys
the head of development the
head of project management and the CEO then
I saw the thing I
asked the three
guys tell me guys lounge that just two
years of development time you
actually tried it yourself look
at me 3 blank faces I knew exactly
no  don't you have
two aren't there anymore one is there
too it's good i'll leave it
there
you can't produce something like that you can't
innovate and produce something like that and believe
when you look at it you know if it
works
we use so we have  just
launched the Womanizer og that's in
November is our new invention
Womanizer universe super cool G-spot
stimulator that was in development for five years
because it was very complex
very demanding to develop it and
we tested it with selected
users from our test panel
about me  I think six or
seven iteration rounds in these five
years and then they get the
prototype 5 sent and then it is
tested and then there are questionnaires
and then they are answered and then
the product team can take the information here again
and say okay we have it
that's learned okay let's
change the change here the angle change
here the strength of the motor and
here somehow it's too hard there needs to be
a little more silicone you know it hurts
and the alignment
of the stimulation wave isn't exactly so please try it
differently  align and so on
and so forth that's
absolutely essential you can't
innovate based on size and rely on your
own team 100% that's too
small the size you need
more representation out there from the market but they
now have a real R&D team not
hearing anything  I mean, what did
Mr. Lemke do before, who somehow came along and
now there is a whole
laboratory of people who follow in his
footsteps, so to speak, continue to develop his ideas, yes, that's
right, we hired
machine engineers, electrical engineers,
quality engineers, product managers,
packaging engineers, designers
and of course
some acquisitions are included  been played
no that's 80 to 90 80 90 percent
but they hired we still have
a core team from Ottawa so the
former vivap
employees who
[music]
we were also able to inspire for this
trip to say okay after ten years of
middle class in Reverb  your buck on
a faster journey with more dynamics
and more steam five of them who
were with us long before that, they are
among the oldest in the company today, i.e.
10 plus years on the hump and they are
developing globally today and the rest of
everything came along
Are you actually still in contact with the
gentleman directing the innovation at the time he
said he was amazing what you did to
my baby we talk
like that twice a year call us on my
birthday or sometimes I call
him when I have a
So I have a question Michael I just noticed this and this
here it was in 2015 do
you still remember or can you still
look at the documents I’m waiting for a
query and then
look
around his idea now you’ve built a group
that tends to
be
me  I think so far so far only very
clearly further ambassadors of our brand
and our product all also invented
and rightly so but totally proud really
cool
madness so what's all there is what
kind of what kind of a journey
and
so great respect for this team
making  to have seen for the gap
but it feels like it's not finished yet,
so maybe we'll talk to each other
again in two years and then
you're somehow up somehow
on the way or just through or something like that
could be yes we very important no yes yes yes yes
yes  how big we both talk
but behind it there are still 900 people
who do all this
we are seven
levels for different areas
okay okay
Johannes I am always
surprised I would have actually
read that somewhere that you had done that
okay amazing and then easy to
research then  yes
contacted and lo and behold it has
become an incredible story I am
very happy that you have told so many times
so
continued success and
thank you one way or another I wish you everything
clear